Hey everybody,
Clyde and I are just hanging out in the backyard trying to make the best of this
lockdown situation. And I hope you are too,
whether you're locked down and quarantined or just roaming the streets,
aimlessly, uh, real quick guys, uh,
wanted to offer you all a free month access@rubinreport.com.
So you can just go to Rubin report.com, enter code at home,
a T H O M E at home,
and you'll get free access to the entire community.
We've got thousands of really interesting people all over the world. There. Uh,
we've got ad free video. We've got ad free podcast, Riva newsfeed.
That's completely not manipulated by any wacky algorithm. Uh,
I own all the content and the user data, no big tech nonsense involved. Uh,
you can communicate with me. You can communicate with other fans. Uh,
we're doing movie afternoons. We've watched a couple movies together,
and then we do a giant zoom chat. We watched a movie contact two weeks ago.
We did Idiocracy last Sunday.
We're going to do a giant dinner night where we're all going to cook the same
dinner and watch each other cook and drink some wine and have some fun.
And there's all, all sorts of other interesting stuff happening over there.
So you can go to Rubin report.com and enter code at home eight
T H O M E.
And you get a month free access and hopefully it'll make the lock down a little
bit easier. And, uh, I look forward to communicating.
You guys.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, check out our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.